you know we can cut the blood
circulation off to his
brain he's about to cut off the
circulation to the dude's brain behind
him if i could get to these small
intestine points
i'm gonna rewind and if he said
intestine points i'm gonna pass out
myself because he cut the circulation
off to my brain if i could get to these
small intestine points
he's squeezing my guy's achilles tendons
he's saying that's gonna cut off his
intestinal circulation which then in
turn will turn off the circulation to
his brain so go try and choke me go i'm
gonna press it one two three
[Music]
he's out i held it for three seconds
that guy needs an academy award why the
biggest snub of the year jumping on lego
every day until i get a girlfriend oh no
not that's so painful so sharp so sharp
oh
this tarsals is how calcaneous
these plants are fashion take some
viagra for the game baby that'll fit
that circulation going right what a lot
of nfl players at least in my day took
viagra because it opens up the blood
vessels a lot of endurance athletes i
don't know what nfl players are popping
viagra before the game i get why you do
it after the game viagra and sildenafel
the the main ingredient in viagra is a
vasodilator so it opens up blood vessels
it was actually initially tested for and
used for pulmonary hypertension so high
blood pressure in your lungs now the
problem is and why i don't recommend
this to people you want your body
deciding where blood flow should go what
you may not realize is viagra has side
effects headaches and visual problems
are actually two of the most common i
honestly have no idea why he does this
um my working theory is that he's stupid
that was adorable that was the cutest
thing i've ever seen in my life
oh
oh
oh
he 360 finger rolled that bad boy wow
that was nice i have trouble just
shooting a basic layup rain dance
making a rain
oh
he's gonna help her out
did he just do chest compressions on her
leg i'm torn i'm torn i'm half ecstatic
that this young child potentially
watched one of my videos and started
doing chest compressions but also at the
same time really disappointed why the
heck is he doing it on her ankle
[Applause]
it's true because kids are actively
trying to figure out if they actually
were hurt and how much something hurts
so if your child happens to fall watch
them see how they react and don't
automatically jump and be very upset
that they fell because that can
translate to more fear more anxiety
is that supposed to be like roulette on
the water because that's really cool i
would do that
oh no we're back with this
the kick is just for effect he's not
even really kicking i feel like this has
become a show now
i don't know if this video was filmed
after the first video and after the
whole uproar from other other doctors
including myself that he shouldn't be
hitting his students in the face he is
barely barely making contact with their
faces barely before he was laying them
out but now when he's hitting their
faces even like the leg kick he's not
really putting full force i hope the
lesson was learned still not ideal still
hitting them in the face people in the
comment section but doesn't it make your
chin stronger no it does the opposite
the more hits you take to the face
unprotected the more likely it is that
you're going to get knocked out in the
future isn't that crazy
okay face kick face kick
front kick
front punch whoa flying punch whoa kick
kick
elbow kick
reverse elbow slap
kick
oh
that has been fake
oh
oh
if i'm ever down and i need cpr
this is how you do chest compressions
okay oh my god i know the joke you're
making but trust me those are not the
chest compressions you want if you ever
found out you want the good ones you
want dr mike on top of you pounding your
chest two inches deep 100 beats per
minute potentially breaking ribs in
order to get you help
what
[Music]
i'm skeptical about this could it be
possible yeah the body's really good at
creating walls around foreign substances
whether we're talking about bacterias or
a piece of glass i don't know about that
one like just the placement of it it
looks like it's in the calf the gastroc
moves a lot i feel like you would feel
it especially with the thickness of that
glass piece vagina steaming no
first of all it's not even vaginal
steaming it's vulvar steaming vagina is
the the pathway to your uterus and your
cervix it's inside i don't think they're
putting steam inside of your body
because that would burn you know what
needs to be steamed
clothes it's not
one is available you sit over a
medicinal steam pot what is a medicinal
steam pot you're just putting names on a
friggin tea kettle one's the vagina and
uterus cleans
you like steam go into a steam room this
is garbage this is misinformation when
you wake up from your nap and you
realize you're at the doctor
oh that's the cutest baby ever
definitely not my doctor's office
because that baby would be stoked to see
me man what up
if you mix olive oil and lemon you will
get lemony olive oil hold on i didn't
even read the fact that it said sex fact
i don't know what i'm about to get a
better result than viagra
[Music]
what use are you trying to get from the
viagra like if you're trying to create a
food topping that tastes good and you're
putting viagra on it it would be a
better result than viagra but if you're
trying to get erections because you have
erectile dysfunction no my friends
viagra is better foods
how does rice make you shorter what is
that and how does corn make you shorter
none of this makes do they explain any
of it
if you ever see me make a video titled
foods that make you shorter unsubscribe
from my channel
how to lose 10 pounds in one month
massage your
why did i think this was going to be
good information first of all massaging
your earlobes cool i love it i touch my
own earlobes all the time has nothing to
do with weight loss but love it
nonetheless
eat slowly good advice not weight loss
advice but good advice nonetheless
coffee does contain caffeine which is a
metabolism upper if you will it speeds
up your metabolism to some degree which
can help you burn calories and if you're
having black coffee you're not adding
all these fatty things to it that people
do when they put a caramel milky cheese
induced grande macchiato
okay in front of the mirror is the worst
freaking advice ever like that's just
some like self-hatred thing terrible i
actually read that in a cosmo thing one
time and i was like
don't eat out of boredom good piece of
advice avoid eating while distracted
because it's very easy to binge eat
while you're distracted because then
you're not in tune with how full you
actually are
oh that's dangerous the fact that he can
touch it wow that's really dangerous
i want to say something but oh this is
fun
if it's true
that's probably my favorite one the ball
and socket joint
so sutures are what's inside your
cranium that they don't actually have a
great amount of movement they can have a
small tiny amount maybe you won't even
feel the amount of movement that those
sutures have michael i'm sick it's dr
michael to you i got a prescription from
doctor can you go and get it for me sure
so doctor's prescription is for headache
leave it on purse
for sore throat cartilage bracelet for
fewer to meet your heels i'm not gonna
lie i wanted a date and somehow we ended
up in the mall because i think i needed
to get a gift for whoever birthday we
were going to or an event we were going
to during ringing the stuff up for the
event that i was going to and i was
bringing this person as my date this was
our second date maybe she looked at me
and she goes
which means in russian how about a purse
for me i vomited in my mouth oh noof is
that a new but if i'm cold you're cold
you gotta come in i love when people try
and tell dog owners that their dogs are
uncomfortable when they have no idea any
information about that dog i was walking
with bear and i'm walking around and i'm
training him and bear loves to get
spanked on his butt like when i when he
i said he's been a good boy like i spank
him on his butt as a congratulations and
he gets all excited he wants to jump on
me that's like his version of play and
some lady comes up to me on the street
i'm assuming her middle name was karen
and she says sir
please don't hit your dog
and i was like
thank you
you love getting spanked you love
getting spanked
a 73 year old algerian woman presented
to an emergency with abdominal pain they
did studies of her abdomen and found
this she had a lithopedian this is a
fetus
who passed away
35 years earlier and weighed 4.5
kilograms
and became calcified in her abdomen this
is insanely rare this would only happen
with an ectopic pregnancy if the fetus
is in the abdomen and then the baby dies
because that's not a hospitable
environment and the patient didn't know
that they were pregnant that baby almost
gets treated as a foreign substance by
the body it starts walling it off much
like it does an abscess or any other
foreign substance for that matter it
creates scar tissue fibrotic tissue
surrounding it calcifications and like
remember we're scanning everyone and
everyone these days in the emergency
rooms and this is not happening
regularly by any means never king here
welcome back to another saturday dinner
here's what we're having
for breakfast lunch and dinner we're
having liver we've got about three or
four ounces of liver we got our bone
marrow so we've got a fresh piece of
femur we're just gonna scoop that mirror
out uh two important things here liver
one of its
other names is nature's multivitamin
because there are a lot of minerals and
vitamins found in the liver there's high
amounts of i believe vitamin a in liver
vitamin a is one of the fat soluble
vitamins deka and fat soluble vitamins
are not ones that can be excreted in
your urine and can actually be stored in
your fat stores which means that it's
very easy to overdo it with vitamin a
especially with the huge amounts that
are found in liver bone marrow contains
a compound called adiponectin which
actually has been linked to lower rates
of diabetes and cardiovascular disease
there's a lot of good vitamins and
minerals in there as well glucosamine
for joint health and while the evidence
on that isn't perfect if you're getting
the natural weight to me it's better
than the supplement way a living
concoction i want to know what to
deliver concoction we're having a couple
of patties today i hope he's not eating
all those patties that's a lot a lot of
meat all these patties are for me some
of you guys think i don't eat all this
food i eat every single patty i eat
every single fry that's a lot of food
caloric intake has got to be huge i
don't know how much exercise he's doing
it's probably a lot i also don't know if
he's supplementing with any kind of
exogenous hormones not making any
presumptions here but it's possible
especially when you're eating huge
amounts like this it's very very
interesting
that's a good exercise my man is not
only doing a farmer's walk with heavy
kettlebells but he's doing it in the
water with added water resistance good
good exercise it says cell phone
reception goes here
and by here that really means this
faraday cage
and that faraday cage
is going to make sure to block all the
emfs this emf thing has been going
around tik tok people being very much
afraid of low level emf what we've seen
is if you have high levels of exposure
way high industrial levels of exposure
it is problematic but low levels don't
show any short-term danger to the human
body when we do long-term studies
there's been some inconclusive results
where there's been some weak studies
that show like maybe there's some tie no
cause and effect but a potential tie
that could exist there's so many risks
in our everyday lives we have to pick
and choose our battles and if i was to
have a conversation with my patient
about whether or not emf should take a
central place in their life of risk
determination i would probably say no
there's other things where we can make
changes and have bigger wins and better
risk reduction than talking about emf we
have a hard shell hyperbaric chamber we
pump in pure
medical grade o2 this is really
interesting because based on zoning laws
and how these things can explode only
certified facilities like hospitals and
places where you have to have a certain
distance away from other commercial
facilities and residential facilities i
believe that you're allowed to have one
of these when it comes to hyperbaric
treatments though there's a lot of
misinformation out there of people
claiming that it cures everything from
cancer to lyme disease to alzheimer's
disease which is complete poo poo it's
never been proven to do any of those
things in fact here's a list of the
things that it's actually been proven to
help with and we use in our hospitals
every single day we have our cold plunge
there's pine needles in here there are
leaves in here there's stuff in here
that you'd probably say you should
probably clean your coal plunge but this
is all earth this is all stuff that's
going to help yeah there's nothing wrong
with having leaves in your cold pledge
like that's not a problem you want to
get that bad boy out
these are painful tick tocs these are
painful memes click here to check that
out as always to happy and healthy and
let's watch some of these memes together
they're really funny and painful
[Music]